where I grew up the dollar store didn't
sell produce I really wonder what the
quality is gonna be is it edible we'll
find out I do not think I could easily
sit down story call your mama tell your
friend talk to your politician send them
a link zero waste journey is back I'm
gonna be making a zero waste meal what
produce from the dollar store where I
grew up the dollar store didn't sell
produce but in California it seems to be
a thing what are we gonna make I've no
idea we're going in blind with no game
plans either it's gonna be beautiful or
to be a disaster I want to be a little
bit of both okay we're looking for
produce look at all these packaging oh
my god there's a pumpkin maybe would
make something with pumpkin because this
there's no packaging shipping some ship
or our diesel song my biggest question
is because the produce is less expensive
I really wonder what the quality is
gonna be yeah there's all the produce
the whole grocery store there's a really
wide variety of produce I'm seeing a lot
of things in packaging but I'm actually
seeing some unpackage things so I do
think we're gonna be able to make
something why does everything have to
have packaging it takes more time more
energy to put things in bag and preserve
it than it does to actually have the
produce come on hey come on come on
look this squash maybe that could be
like the base of yeah you know we could
do we could make a pasta with spaghetti
squash cuz you can use the spaghetti
squash as pasta that'd be great and
avocados I don't know for what but I
always get avocados maybe we can make a
pesto sauce with the avocado
so we need garlic and walnuts I found a
package free corn I don't see any other
corns oh we can have asparagus this is
pretty unpackaged yeah we're not
I love pomegranate pomegranates - a
little sweet treat for the kids
oh the garlic I think we might have to
do it because we do need garlic growing
up I definitely went to the dollar store
a lot I have a lot of great memories and
especially I don't know someone like me
who grew up in a food desert the town
that I lived in with my family and most
of Carolina all they had was a Dollar
General and a gas station I like that
Dollar Stores exists because sometimes
they give opportunities and food
resources to neighborhoods that don't
really have it every time when I was
little before I went to the movies with
my dad we'd come to the dollar store and
then we buy a bunch of candy and then
I'd stuff it in my coat and sneak it
into the movies honestly that's what my
mom taught me the love of the big purse
so here's some nuts
we got the nuts but can we find walnuts
and they're all in packaging here we go
walnuts perhaps there's a more
zero-waste mill that we could make
butter you have to make a meal somehow
maybe there's a multiple places are
usually you want to get a wine an
affordable meal at an affordable price
Iko I'm excited Lulu you are Z the last
stop
we're about to prep the spaghetti squash
I'm gonna cut it in half this is sick
she's chaotic with them oh this is not
tasty this is yes you're not tasting
terror RDP isn't cutting it for us oh
wow we're gonna get it prepped Oh Rose
I'm gonna stab it with a fork a bunch of
times
thank you like this let's think about on
that
now we're gonna take out the scenes it's
gonna compost it for the environment
back to the soil from whence it came
you know you sound like a witch well I
don't think that's completely we're
putting olive oil on the squash or
putting salt and pepper and we're
putting it face down on the camera so
I'm gonna cut off the ends of these
asparagus okay I don't know if all the
knives in my house suck there we go now
we're going to put salt pepper and oil
on those burgers we're assuming everyone
has salt and pepper and oil at their
home so we didn't get that at the dollar
store and now they go in the oven how
long are we gonna bake it we're gonna
bake the asparagus and spaghetti squash
for about 30 minutes okay I'll set a
timer
oh what a power press is your waist is
cool but it's not just up to the
individual click we also need
corporations and governments to take
some action yeah those cats are hasn't
had time usually do when people are
around why they like to show off yeah
they like to play and be stars
what are we gonna do with these
pomegranates should we put them on the
asparagus for a sign should we do fresh
corn or do you want to saute it it's
alright I'm gonna you know I hate making
decisions but that's it I'm actually
excited for this meal I think it's gonna
be tasty delish we're having like very
kernel centric food today cuz we your
arms like a pomegranate kernels and I
mean there's more in kernels like so
like you go friendly like a no animal
has been died in this meal you know I
love a little bit of a vibe from the
cupboard
Oh certainly pestle I don't know if we
can actually call it a pesto because we
don't have a cheese element it's more
like a avocado sauce I can open these
I'm not used to plastic anymore ok we're
gonna blend up the walnuts she couldn't
have a cop at Oh everyone know
boop-boo-boo-boop avocado and now we add
garlic avocado we're gonna add the olive
oils we're gonna salt it keep it salty
[Music]
shall we try it yeah let's try it okay
yeah
does it need anything else I've been a
little more salt it tastes like pesto
it's like those vegan sister the squash
and asparagus are ready whoo yummy it's
very steamy the start spaghetti in this
is riveting yeah looks pretty easy
squash that somehow looks like spaghetti
that's mind-blowing
vighati what catalyst babies this is
like the perfect date food I might make
my own sauce from now on we're gonna put
that pistol in babe in nothing looks
pretty in every dude no way I can't tell
if it looks appetizing or not you know
it at this point I think it'll taste
that good smells good
we'd have our delicious pasta we have
our asparagus and we have our corn which
we're gonna put in spaghetti squash and
top of the pomegranates on the asparagus
wow dude Wow would you ever think that
this was all from the dollar store
I literally have this full meal with
full wine from blue Dallas to uh cheers
to the dollar store you ready to try it
I am I really what whoa that was worried
that at the dollar store we wouldn't be
able to find anything package free
mm-hmm but for a whole meal this is
really not that bad for drought and this
is the food waste but look if I go back
into the earth looking for lots of
ground it's gonna make more food yeah
we're gonna compost this I think that we
kind of showed you can be zero waste on
a budget you can I think I'll definitely
gonna make more meal from the dollar
store good we're gonna charge like
you're freaking me $40 we are gonna
start a business where we just source
food from the dollar store and then
charge $60 of play literally
[Music]